daniel puskepeleitis ist für uns bei
hannover in der kleingartenanlage vor
alles umgegraben wurde guten morgen
daniel schon guten morgen
was wollen jetzt bei den grabungen
gefunden was haben die grabungen ergeben
zwei tage lang wurde hier gebuddelt und
jeder stein wurde umgedreht
etwa 30 polizisten und das bka waren
hier vor ort zuständig ist die
staatsanwaltschaft in braunschweig die
informiert bislang aber nicht über die
funde ob etwas gefunden wurde
was gefunden worden sein könnte es ist
ein großes geheimnis nach wie vor die
staatsanwaltschaft hat sich offen
gelassen ob sie diese woche noch
informiert nach unseren informationen
wird das nicht mehr geschehen
wahrscheinlich wird es frühestens
nächste woche erkenntnisse geben grund
christian b will ja auch vorzeitig aus
der haft entlassen werden der
verteidiger hat jetzt einen
entsprechenden antrag gestellt was
bedeutet denn jetzt diese nervt hat
nervt taktik des verteidigers von
christian b nun christian b hatte
bereits ein antrag auf haftentlassung
gestellt hatte den dann wieder
zurückgezogen angeblich weil er kein
vertrauen in die zuständige justiz dem
raum sprich hat jetzt ist eine andere
staatsanwaltschaft eine andere ein
anderes gericht zuständig die zuständige
staatsanwaltschaft gibt diesen erneuten
antrag auf haftentlassung wenig chancen
auf aussicht aber ich habe den eindruck
der verteidiger versucht eine sehr
offensive verteidigungsstrategie weil er
gleichzeitig auch davon gesprochen hat
medienberichten zufolge dieses ausgraben
dieses buddeln in hannover sei eine
verzweiflungstat der staatsanwaltschaft
und der verteidiger ist überzeugt auch
ein zitat von ihm die staatsanwaltschaft
setzt auf das falsche pferd